vous-même ayant été attaqué sur les gars
du bijou est ce que vous faites plus
particulièrement attention aujourd'hui
on dit que les services juridiques des
maisons d'édition sont peu constamment
sur la brèche qui s'attendent toujours
aux attaques aux dénonciations
c'est votre cas non pas forcément mais
parce que parce que je ne souhaite pas
en fait c'est une démarche aussi de
faire attention c'est compliqué de
savoir comment se défendre contre ce
genre âge à garder votre émission lierre
sur la grande salle culture c'est
compliqué de savoir comment comment
répondre ces attaques
il croit que la première réponse c'est
de continuer comme avant en fait de deux
pas de pas timide et timorée le pas
avoir peur
l'aria toujours la peur de se faire
tomber dessus etc
c'est pas simple moi quand il ya eu le
petit problème sur la guerre des bisous
franchement c'était pas simple c'est pas
évident je me suis posé la question de
savoir est ce que faisait le dos rond et
ce que je rentrais dedans bon j'ai
décidé de rentrer dedans et de prendre
l'initiative
meas et c'est un évident c'est fatigant
c'est pas drôle on lit des insultes sur
soi rien de grenat ça mais en même temps
voilà je pense que la liberté d'écriture
est tellement liée aux métiers des
clients moins deux gars je sens que j'ai
pas le choix je sens que justement si je
suis parti dans cette profession a après
avoir complètement raté mon parcours
scolaire
c'est justement bref que ça m'offrait un
endroit pour votre livre pour m'amuser
pour être voilà ce que je voulais c'est
très important pour moi de dire ce que
je voulais je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
ont encore des espaces pour répondre
[Musique]